hi i'm tommy innit and this is the wired
auto complete interview
this chair is not as comfy as it looks
on other videos by the way
who was tommy in it
here we go who was it tommy in it's
first subscriber
honestly i think it was my friend
freddie badly he watched all of my first
streams he was just in all of the chats
always one of the things i did was to
boost my videos performance i'd sign
into an alt account and watch all of my
videos all the way through
to try to try and uh try and boost the
algorithm but freddie would do that as
well because because he's my first
subscriber the only problem was we we
did this until i had like a hundred
thousand subscribers so it was very it
was really
really stupid to keep doing
who is
better dreamer tommy in it me obviously
me dream he's a good man he's a cheater
but he's a good man i'm better than him
i've got more character got more looks i
don't even i don't even know what dream
looks like he won't tell anyone only
sapnap knows which is which is weird who
made tommy in its
skin well i think i found it on the
minecraft skin decks it was like a
version of it with brown hair and i just
re-pasted it to have this top it was i
think it was i have two versions of this
top and it was this is like the very
first one and i just retextured it so he
did do a little bit of the old
plagiarism but at the end of the day no
one minds
who is tommy in it
best friend it would either be tubbo or
wilbur or freddy okay it's chucking time
what is tommy in its
real name
thomas simons no one calls me thomas i
think the dumb doctors do or my mum
what time is it where tommy in it live i
think right now it's like half past
three but you can't tell because i'm in
the ethereal void that is the wired
shoot but what time i'm usually live
usually like 8 p.m on twitch but i don't
really stream
i'm more of a vlogger what is tommy in
its setup yeah my setup's all right i've
got
like two monitors because i'm not known
for being any good at the video games i
i just make the jokes
what did tommy in
it name his pickaxe
i don't know
what is the funniest video ever tommy in
it i really like some of the among his
videos was this one where i joined
pokemane's call and just made wilbert my
uh my older brother like really awkward
that was probably one of the ones i've
had the most fun with but some of the
recent ones we just filmed a grand theft
auto 5 video like i feel like we always
have a good a good giggle and laugh what
we're doing you know why is tommy in it
in the book of world records yeah i have
this is really weird i have two guinness
book of world records and i didn't do
any work for them i got a message from
my friend jax looks at life and he was
like hey i'm doing this video
do you want some and i went yeah sure
how much is it
and he went 20 pounds literally it was
for his video and he did all the signing
up all the calling that were and i just
sat there just one day i had these world
records arrive and i went
okay yeah
um
i was telling it on the swedish news so
about last year when i started growing
quite fast i got quite a lot of emails
from like all of the new sites being
like hey do you want to come on and i
sat on my dad and we were going listen
like i kind of do i want to go on the
news but i don't
like i don't want to go on all of these
ones i want to do it funny so me and my
dad who sort of helps me with emails and
[ __ ] made a pledge to only ever go on
the swedish news sites uh because we
thought it was funny and so i did and
there's one where i'm on the swedish
news and turbo is just sat
dead silent in the background the entire
time uh but now i'm thinking i might i
might go on some of the other news shots
sweden's had its fun i feel like i've
got as big as i can in sweden uh so i
think it might be time to to expand out
of that
why is tommy in it in the bella porch
music video she saw just message going
do you want to be in it i went
okay and then i showed up um at the
studio which weirdly was also my college
because my college doubles up as a
studio so i was going into college but
this time as a bell boy and tommy and it
was really really weird but it was quite
strange wasn't it i feel like i should
be in more music videos i feel like i
give them the touch of character that
they need
what's really crying i don't think i've
ever cried on a stream or anything which
is you know i keep it i keep it together
why is tommy in it so tall six foot
three
why well my dad is like six foot six
foot five um i guess it's just i guess
it's just in my blood i guess i'm just
awesome i don't know why i'd like to
keep going though i don't want to stop i
feel like the taller i get the more
power i get so i could really do with it
oh my god
when did tommy get his braces off oh
yeah i forgot i had them wiry things on
my teeth for years i think i got my
braces off
i can't remember actually it was so
weird
i remember when they took them off my
mouth was all like slimy for the day i
had my braces on for bloody ages but
yeah thank god they're gone when will
tommy in it
hit 10 million yeah i hit 10 million i
have it on youtube and on tick tock and
i've got the little trophy as well but
it's very very grubby when is tommy lips
going to stop streaming
aggressive when am i going to quit i
really like streaming i mean
i used to stream daily like like
every day and i've sort of simmered out
over the past year to maybe once every
week every two weeks and then i get
really into it i get into my groove i
don't think i'm gonna quit
streaming i like i love it when did
tommy in it
get the discs ah
the minecraft discs from the dream smp
we had a big finale stream i got them
all back then and i've had them just
sitting in my under chest since then but
i don't know i could see a world where
something's coming up but no not that
i've spoiled any plans but yeah we
battled for them back and then
puns and the gang just kid just really
clutches up is tommy in it
that was not worth the reveal is tommy
and a child so yes you know what i can
finally say yes right now right now i'm
a child but the video comes out after my
birthday so when you're watching this
i'll be a man i'll be honest you can all
comment going wow what a big man he is
is tommy in it
a billionaire yes i [ __ ] i'm a
billionaire i have so
much money
that's for me
and if i'm not then you'll never know is
tommy in it in no way home
that would be awesome i think one of my
bucket list things is to be canon to the
mcu like that would be so cool and i'm
getting there giving andrew garfield
beside in an identical chair to this one
not the same but an identical one in los
angeles is tommy in it
no i know i got this don't worry
a theater kid i think so i think i am i
did a lot of acting in school i
specifically remember performing
footloose in front of the entirety of my
academy i did yeah musical back to the
80s i was the villain can you believe
that me uh i was the villain and it
ended with me getting karate kicked in
the face this is not this is like five
years ago as well this is not a long
time ago and i did a little shop of
horrors and i was seymour i was the main
smashed it but for the past few years
i've just been a minecraft kid switching
up a bit
it's tommy and it made in a lab
these have been a serious set of weird
questions wired uh out or google
whoever's to blame but no no i wasn't
made in a
lab
tommy and it's cow's name when i did the
dream smp i had a cow that got brutally
murdered named henry and he was
brilliant and beloved and is dead this
is a long boy tommy in it
has the voice of an angel thank you
google uh i've done a little bit of
singing in the past i i always open up
my streams by humming a little thing
but i've been getting older now my voice
keeps cracking everywhere i go i need
help tommy in it
mr beast that's that's
dave beast jimmy i mean i know i keep
showing up in his gaming videos him and
my dad had an argument the other day he
put on his um his story about how he has
a real life lightsaber i mean my dad was
saying that's not real life jimmy first
of all they don't have chords because it
would stick to your back second of all
it can't chop through things he got he
got very
very quickly angry about that i think
he's evil but yeah he's cool he's insane
but he's cool tommy in it ramp up oh
tommy beat gordon ramsay oh gordon well
so i
gordon has the most tick tock followers
uh in the of all the english people and
i wanted to try and pass him and then he
briefly messaged me and he went hey can
we duet you and i went yeah sure and i'm
still waiting on gordon i think it's
still a little bit confusing but he's a
very angry man he definitely doesn't
deserve all of the tick tock followers
in the world it makes no sense i'm
awesome
oh no okay
done with this board
big one come in
how am i so bad at the wired ultra
complete interview this is not no one
else has struggled with
this does tommy in it know how to play
piano yes i'm a grade 5 jazz pianist i
did piano lessons for nine years i can
sight read chords like you just give me
a g tab and i'll just i just sit and i
can do it um but i can't really read
sheet music anymore or be like proper
goods but
i know there's one jazz song i can play
over and over and over
yeah does john cena follow me he does
he's never replied to me okay i'll set
that out in the open i think he follows
like
half a million people
which begs the question john are you
really invested in the tommy in at
universe like you should be i don't
think john cena is passionate about me
like i'm about him but it's fine
does tommy in it need glasses i booked
to go to the optician yesterday i'm now
on the cancellation list in boots so if
someone else pulls out i'm going in so
if you live in brighton and uh are going
to the opticians please cancel because i
need to i haven't gone to the opticians
in like five years does tommy in it
tommy you have a crush on the queen i
think i do but as time's going on and
i'm getting older you know my senses are
maturing i'm sort of realizing me
there's only so much rejection someone
can take a constant
ignoring and when i show up outside her
house her palace and she just ignores me
until it's just
just painful does tommy in it
reply to dms you know what i think for
the past few years i've been really good
at replying to everyone's messages but
recently i'll admit i've been slipping
off i've been falling off
how did tommy in it come up with his
name so tommy is because i i'm called
tom and i always thought tommy was the
cooler version of tom and i always
wanted to secretly be called tommy and
then in it was um yeah just everyone
around where i lived said it all the
time i really liked it it felt very like
personal to me and i said edit loads and
my mom did right i think the first time
i ever used it was in a geography lesson
when you had to come up with your
username and that's when i wrote it down
for like my show my homework vlogging or
something i was like i'm not going to go
by tom simons i'm going to be the cool
kid in geography i'm going to go by
tommy in it it wasn't cool and i
remember the teacher going why why did
you name yourself that and i went
uh and that was and then i never used it
again at school
how to play with tommy in it i play on
minecraft hypixel i play a lot of bed
wars but i'm usually like hidden but you
if you just play bad wolves every night
you'll probably end up going against me
or pub g i'm usually on those games how
fast does tommy in it type i'm a i'm an
awesome typer i see you know how people
type like like that with all fours like
that i don't i just go i type like how
an old woman would type like that but
i've done it for so many years for like
six years i've been typing like that i
go
and i'm pretty i'm pretty good at it how
to cosplay tommy in it you're gonna need
the wig you're gonna need this guy and
then you're gonna start shouting [ __ ]
and swear a lot and go hello and then
you'll be on your way how is tommy in it
growing so fast i mean i just make quite
a lot of videos i think i do like two
every like two a week at the moment and
i put quite a lot of thought into the
idea of what we're making and producing
them it's all i do and i'm
cool wired and the wired audience thank
you for having me i feel like a proper
celebrity now which and that is
i'm breaking the chair